okay hi everyone well this morning this
afternoon whatever time it is for you uh
we have a slightly different thing we're
looking at we are looking at Jonathan
gorod's work on a system for using our
uh wolfen model physics project ideas to
make a
gravitation general relativity
simulation solving system
and that's uh um okay over to Jonathan
maybe who will Who will now deny that my
description is correct no no I think
that's a perfectly reasonable
description but I I think it's important
to distinguish a few different
objectives with this framework
so the the first is that okay the first
is a very pragmatic thing which is that
in general
numerical gr simulations are quite hard
to set up if you're not you know if
you're sort of standard user
um so the the usual workflow is I mean
because okay to
backtracked for a second for any
practical numerical relativity
simulation you're going to have a lot of
equations and they're going to be pretty
complicated as you know if you're if
you're simulating you know General
relativistic
Magneto hydrodynamics you know plasma
flow onto a spinning black hole or
something you could easily have 100 plus
sort of um partial differential
equations that you have to solve so no
one's going to implement that by hand so
the standard workflow has now become
that you write the equations in some
kind of abstract notation in Wolfram
language or or a similar system
um and then you run some package that
then does automatic code generation from
that so uh there's a probably the most
widely used packages that's more of a
language package called Crank which does
this
um where you you enter essentially a
tensor equation in Einstein notation and
it goes away and it synthesizes
um C code which you can then plug oh
usually it's C code sometimes it's
Fortran or something which you can then
plug into uh you know Cactus or whiskey
or gr chombo or whatever other numerical
relativity code then you go run that it
produces some data files you then put
you import the data files back into some
other system uh there's like packages
like nrpi which is a python package that
does the analysis and visualization and
extracts of Enterprise and informations
or information or gravitational wave
data or whatever so it's a slightly
fiddly workflow so the first objective
with this is to is to make it so that
you could do everything just within one
notebook so you can set up the initial
data set up all the coordinate systems
you know um equip the equip the space
time with Mata Fields run the simulation
get the results back visualize them
analyze and Etc all within one instance
um and then and then as you say Stephen
the other aspect of this is the the
Wolfram model aspect which is the
realization that
um when you're doing a numerical
simulation with adaptive refinement
um you are refining your grid structure
based on you know certain information
about the you know usually based on
projections of curvature tensors and
things
and so then you have some rule that
tells you when to refine when to coarsen
the the you know the the the the mesh
topology
um and so in effect what you're doing is
you're defining a hypography writing
system but where the rewriting order is
determined by the evolution of the PDS
um so it's really adjustable for model
rule with some slightly odd event
selection function and then the other
exciting the other aspects of that is
that you can then reconstruct certain
information about the curvature from the
topology
um and so that so in fact there's you
reach a point where you can just throw
away the information about the pde
system and you just have the pure
hypography writing Rule and that's sort
of the the that's that's how the
numerical side of this works
um but okay so let me just uh if I show
what's your favorite metric
um these are the ones we currently
support
okay okay uh so if I say metric tensor
so
it's a matrix representation
Matrix form okay so this is lower index
you know this is the ordinary metric
tensor for the current metric uh we've
got symbolic and symbolic J for uh the
mass and the quote unquote angular
momentum parameter respectively
um and this is in standard boilingquist
coordinates
by the way let me make a general content
I mean you know in the world of pdes
setting up
the system
is you know that's been a huge roadblock
in in everything to do with pdes and
we've been you know it took us a couple
of decades to have the kind of
computational geometry capabilities
necessary to you know Define
multi-dimensional pdes in a reasonable
way and you know I think
yeah it's interesting in this case
because
you know the things that we've
introduced in the last few years in for
sort of standard pdes have been
uh
you know I'm just Jonathan I assume
you've looked at this stuff all the
stuff to do with
um you know dirichlet condition
Etc et cetera et cetera these these kind
of symbolic rappers that represent
different
kind of right right I I have um although
I I don't I mean I don't claim to know
that much about it I've looked at the
documentation for them yeah
but uh but I mean as you also probably
aware setting up initial data for the
Einstein equations is even more
difficult than it is I know TDE Systems
um so okay if we skip ahead for that to
that just for a second I mean so the
standard way we do that in in gravitas
is we have this thing ADN decomposition
uh where so if I give that the Cur
geometry so so the import there's an
important like philosophical distinction
here right there's there's much if I say
metric tens occur that gives me the
entire space-time metric as one kind of
Big Blob but for solving the ancient
equations numerically that's not you
know you don't know that in general you
just have some initial data
um and this is probably uh
sorry I'm gonna do something a little
bit incompressible here but I'll explain
what I'm doing in a second
um let's say ADM
all right spatial metric tensor
so with ADM decomposition what that
allows you to do okay okay actually let
me start with a simpler ADM
decomposition
let's do shots Shields because that's
diagonal
so here what we're doing is we're saying
let's imagine we didn't know the
space-time form of the Schwartz child
metric suppose we just had the data for
an initial koshy surface for an initial
space like hypersurface so
that would be
this thing here right yep
um and then it's and so what ADM
decomposition says is we'll then show me
symbolically what the space time metric
tensor would look like if I were to
evolve the Einstein equations from that
initial data so if I say space time
metric tensor Matrix Four okay so we get
this
um and so this is uh so here we see in
this sub this three by three sub Matrix
is the spatial metric it's the initial
spatial metric tense
and then this stuff you see a bunch of
things related to Alpha and beta so
Alpha is this lapse function beta is the
shift Vector
um and these are your gauge variables
these determine effectively your
SpaceTime coordinate system so if you
like Alpha tells you how you foliate the
space time and beta tells you how you
relabel the spatial coordinates As you
move from one leaf of the foliation to
another Leaf of the foliation right let
me just to make sure I understand this
so I mean in the
that spatial metric tensor is on a space
like hypersurface that's
the that's the way that you measure
distances on that space like
hypersurface
now you're asking you're saying I see I
see I I get what's going on so you've
got this foliated space-time going
forwards in this ADM decomposition and
this is now telling you how to measure
distances in that foliated world where
the distances you know where you have to
measure sort of leaf to leaf or the
sheet to sheet distances and that's
determined by the alpha parameter is
right
okay and so then the point is that you
can set up initial data for uh even even
for metrics where you don't know or that
it where there isn't an analytical
solution for the whole space time right
so so what ADM decomposition lets you do
is for instance you can say Evolution
equations
and it will go away and it will grind
for a second and it will produce the
complete pde system for the ADM
decomposition that so this is a system
of hyperbolic a couple hyperbolic pdes
that evolves this initial data forwards
in time relative to this foliation okay
just just time to for flat space time
that space-time metric tensor in the ADM
decomposition is what it's a time it's a
Time evolving what does it look like and
is it uh okay so if we take it with an
alpha and beta and the time coordinate
so if we take a three by three euclidean
metric we use that as our initial space
like hypersurface
I'd say space time metric tensor
is that
okay I was ex okay hold on so in a sense
rather than defining these stances what
this is doing if you have two slices of
the foliation it's determining which
point
will correspond to which point in the
next foliation in the next slice of the
foliation right exactly so so Alpha is
telling you the time like distance
between the neighbor you know between
corresponding points on neighboring
slices beta is telling you the space
like distance between the yep running
points okay again it's like the shear
right so there is no obviously a
connection with a vertical connection
right yeah so you you the which which is
here will vary with time so to speak
exactly yeah varies with time exactly
okay
um and and so so okay in this case here
we've we've not specified any gauge
conditions right so Alpha Beta
completely undetermined but you know ADM
decomposition for instance has a bunch
of gauge conditions built in so uh in
the simplest case we could say uh gb6
slicing condition and that would just be
Alpha as identically one but we could
also say
um I've actually forgotten which
coordinate conditions I've introduced
now but like I think Maximus
and what's the discovery interface for
figuring out what conditions exist well
it's probably more Jose's area than mine
um
Discovery as in in the system in in your
gravitas system what does it how does it
um oh right okay so okay the point is
all of these can be these these are all
computations that can be characterized
by just abstract tensor equations right
so the maximum slicing condition is is
given just you know or you know things
like the uh we have like things like
minimal Distortion conditions and so on
those are all represented in terms of
just tensor equations actually for the
extrinsic curvature tensor on the space
like hypersurface
um and or typically in terms of the
extrinsic tensor so all we're doing is
we're taking those tensor equations
we're unrolling them and possibly doing
some simplification so if we say reduced
simple slicing condition it will do some
simplification it keeps there's code
internally for keeping track of various
algebraic identities and things that
enable us to do um canonicalization
although not very efficiently uh
um so Jonathan let me say one thing here
so so the metric is or it has Freedom
here which is this gauge Freedom which
corresponds to the alpha and beta so the
same metric can be re-expressed for
difference Alpha and betas differently
so that's why we have to impose some
conditions that will
find the metric in a given choice of
Alpha and beta but in some situations we
have to solve for Alpha and beta at the
same time that we solve for the rest of
the metric
which is the slightly different scenario
so we are using PDS like in anti-solve
to have the metric predetermined and to
impose conditions on a given geometry
sign so here we will be solving
simultaneously for the metric and for
the geometry
wait a minute when you say solving for
the geometry your describing that the
ADM parameters the alphas and betas is
that what do you mean by solving for the
geometry are you solving for the
alphasis I mean alphas and betas have a
lot of freedom they have a lot of gauge
freedom but not exactly so so the
typical thing in any sort of will be
that we have already a coordinate system
we know what the lines are and we are
solving for functions on that coordinate
system here we impose some conditions on
Alpha and beta like the Divergence of
beta is something but with an obita beta
itself is going to be solved together
with the rest of the functions of the
metric
the coordinates will be determined by
Beta but we don't know beta yet at the
very end we know simultaneously the
metric and beta and Alpha so at the end
we discover which coordinates we have
and which metric we have
if we had a imposed different core
conditions on Alpha and beta we would
arrive at different functions Alpha Beta
and different functions for the rest of
the metric but the physical metric will
be the same it's just expressing
different coordinates like this is
covered at the end
right and they're presumably I mean if
you put the wrong conditions on our from
beta it may not be solvable there may
not be a metric that has
that there may not be a simultaneous
solution for Alpha Beta and the metric
exactly we may discover a coordinate
system that collapses or gets singular
very soon for example if the conditions
in alphabet are bad I mean for instance
and this is this is for instance why
things like maximal slicing were
initially developed and why people paid
so much attention to things like the
OnePlus log slicing conditions and the
gamma driving conditions because there
was essentially a bunch of empirical
work to determine which gauge conditions
had nice Singularity avoidance
properties for things like black hole
simulations right and and when it fails
Jose you were describing one you
discovered that when it fails it fails
because there isn't existence for all
time it just the whole thing the thing
implodes somehow is that right right
there are singularities in the in the
in in the functions you are integrating
and and of course you have to be very
careful because you don't know whether
that's according Singularity or a
physical Singularity if it's a physical
Singularity it's going to appear in all
choices of coordinates but if it's
according similarity you might find some
other conditions on Alpha Beta
and the gauge integrated Freedom it took
like 50 years for people to realize that
Singularity wasn't coordinating together
if it wasn't a physical one that's not
that's not quite true actually I was
looking at the the history of this for
this new paper that um I mean the Metra
worked it out about 15 years after like
in in the 1930s
um it's just no one really no one paid
any attention to him but wasn't didn't
it take Crisco coordinates and things
like that before people really
understood that the coordinates
singularity in the short shot metric
wasn't a physical okay yes so so the
crystal extension is one way of becoming
convinced that it's a true Singularity
but um the maitrea had actually made the
argument that's
I think a perfectly reasonable argument
that well you know the Freshman scaler
diverges right so it it and and we know
that's a you know that's it but I was
talking about the singularity at the
Event Horizon exactly in the original
but that's that's my point right so the
Metro had developed the medical
coordinates which had which would just
like Eddington Finkelstein or like ume
got rid of the coordinate Singularity at
R equals to M uh but then he made that
he in his paper he made this like
parenthetical remark about how the you
know the the one at R equals naught has
a Divergence of this green money and
curvature invariant and therefore it's
probably not removable in this way and
then yeah okay
so he knew but basically you're saying
he knew that there wasn't a genuine
coordinate Singularity at R equals 2m
yeah but but yeah exactly and and but
people knew that well okay actually the
the history is a bit complicated
like Eddington invented the Eddington
Finkelstein coordinate system but didn't
realize that it got rid of the
coordinate Singularity it invented it
for a completely different reason and it
was David Finkelstein who realized that
it got rid of the corner similarity
um so different people knew different
things at different times but
interesting but I mean it took it took
until the 1950s didn't tell people
understood that that wasn't
a um probably in a mainstream sense yeah
okay anyway just just I'm just trying to
understand okay difficult questions all
right
okay uh but yeah I mean and Stephen it's
worth commenting on that sort of one of
the tips I mean sorry the typical way
that numerical gr simulations crash is
that you end up with Gauge conditions
that sort of stretch your coordinate
system infinitely in some direction
right that's that's normally that that's
usually the way they fail
so maybe I'm jumping too far but but in
our kind of models yeah where
sort of so in in the Wolfram model case
that that sort of crash mode would be
one where you're you're only updating
one region of the hypograph and so there
are subgraph sub-hypographs that are
just not getting updated
um and so so to evolve to a genuinely
non-overlapping space like hypersurface
would require an infinite amount of
computation right because the because
the um the bit they're not evolving is
never going to evolve so to speak right
so in other words the coordinate what
you're saying is
in a kind of
these choices of coordinates are
determining
where the update activity is happening
exactly and
in order to have a
sort of
so the point is that in the discrete
case these alphas and betas have a very
direct
expression right the alpha is how many
causalegers you Traverse from what
events to into the event on the
neighboring hypersurface beta is the
hypograph distance between the
application points of the corresponding
events right lovely
okay um
okay so uh what would that maybe I
should maybe I should show some of the
numerics I mean I'm trying to give you
some indication of how we set up the
initial conditions how we handle gauge
Freedom there's a lot more to say about
this well just give me some sense I mean
if I if I wanted two black holes playing
in the in this okay so for that okay
again you may have noticed this before
when we did when we called Kerr with
complete gauge Freedom it didn't
evaluate because it's just like too
complicated
um but so I'm gonna have to restrict the
gauge Freedom a lot uh to make this
evaluate but if I do this
um
so there are many ways to set up
um analytic forms of the black hole
binary initial data this is actually
let's maximally constrain the gauge
conditions
this is a typical one the real Lindquist
initial data
so
that's representing a single black hole
no no a binary black hole system
so you have enough parameters to do that
well I mean as you see there are
defaults for everything right so here we
you can see uh this is so this is the
geometry uh actually let's show the
spatial so R is the distance between the
sanctions black holes a1a2 are the the
sizes of the black holes or something uh
no actually R is the radial coordinates
um so so uh and that we we're assuming
for um Simplicity that both black holes
have mass m and uh Z naught minus Z
naught and plus Z naught are the are the
initial positions of the two singular of
the two you know R equals to the black
holes
um so uh so Brill Lindquist is one way
to do it there's also misnometrics and
other things and effectively they
correspond to different so the the way
you set up analytic data for a binary
black hole simulation like this is you
essentially you more or less set up a
wormhole
um space time because because you you a
wormhole space like hypersurface
um and then you treat the two mouths of
the wormholes being
um as being the two black holes that are
colliding
um so so wait a second so is it the case
that I mean if I just tell you here are
a bunch of Center coordinates for a
bunch of black holes can you write down
initial data that corresponds to that
sort of field of black holes there is a
there is a generalized misnometric for
uh for yeah for essentially lattices of
black holes but not I mean can I place
black holes at arbitrary positions in a
you know like I'm placing hard spheres
or something and some Hardware gas
simulation not not analytically what you
would need to do is uh is do a sort of
relaxation is apply a relaxation
algorithm or something to to set up the
initial data for that and the reason you
can't do it analytically is I'm just
trying to understand is is that because
there's not an obvious space like
hypersurface where simultaneously there
are all these black holes just hanging
out
and uh well I mean there's yeah there's
not an obvious space like hyper surface
which which admits a closed form metric
I see
um
and and by by that you mean so each
black hole on its own has a well-defined
metric but when you bring them together
I see I see it's not obvious that you
can get a consistent metric that
represents the combination of all those
black holes I mean it's actually a total
fluke that we can even do this in the
binary case and as I say it's a flu
these come about from I think they're
often referred to as trumpet Solutions
in the OR trumpet initial data in in the
numerical relativity literature way
because you're yeah you're essentially
you're defining a kind of wormhole-like
solution that looks like a trumpet
um and then you're but but you know um
and actually that's the key difference
between the brill Lindquist and the
misner metrics is that they just have
slightly different topologies it depends
on whether you treat it the space time
as being one sheeted or two sheeted
um but yeah then the idea is you bring
the kind of two mouths of the trumpet
together and you and you Collide those
um and that you know acts like a binary
black hole system but this type of
solution
is a solution that contains a
singularities but it's not a realistic
solution so if you put this in into a
numerical code the first thing you will
see is that it relaxes it's it it kind
of sends to Infinity a lot of
gravitational radiation and then it
relaxes towards real
uh situation with two more realistic
black holes right right exactly
um okay so people have to wait for some
time until until these
evolves into something more realistic
that you could say these are two black
holes
and so yeah it's pretty standard that
people will just cut I mean I I referred
to as different things but it's often
it's called things like ringing noise or
relaxation noise you know there's
basically a bunch of cruds that gets
produced at the start of the simulation
and you just kind of ignore that and and
you look at the later time behavior I'm
trying to understand an analogy for this
I mean it's kind of like if you had a
mechanical system and you said
I'm going to simulate this thing under
you know this configuration of of um
I mean it's actually a lot like
um it's a lot like Riemann problems in
fluid mechanics that's a good one
actually mathematically it's pretty much
identical
um so when you set up a you know you set
up a shock tube problem or something
with an initial discontinuity
um the standard approach if you're doing
an explicit time Evolution scheme is
that you drop the the CFL you drop the
current number uh normally by a factor
of about five for the first few time
steps and the reason is because you're
going to introduce a bunch of numerical
instabilities around and dispersions
around this around the discontinuity
until it relaxes and you see exactly the
same thing so it's probably the same
sound waves as well I mean really
exactly exactly yeah exactly okay
and yeah so this that's um I think in
Toro's book on numerical analysis he
calls it like um initialization
stabilization or whatever
so it's a standard pde problem
right okay I get it okay all right so
yeah so this is how you'd set up a you
know a binary black hole system or
something
um yeah sorry
um okay so so maybe I should say a
little bit about uh about the actual
numerics side so if we take a metric
that's that I'm going to try and pick
one that I think we can solve in a
reasonable time online not so great
laptop
um so if I say shots chills
Mass one uh and let's let me not use the
default formal coordinates let me use
tr1a uh yeah okay uh and let's do
say time between zero and one
R between 0 and 4 say A1 between minus
Pi Pi so I'm just giving it some some
coordinates to to use uh or some
coordinate conditions to use uh and then
let's say let's do 400
so I mean just talking about design here
for a second I mean and and I'm kind of
trying to understand when you have these
tra1a2
is that I mean that depends on the
metric what what those parameters are is
that correct or is that not correct so
those are not exactly parameters okay so
okay so go into the design question if
we take curve right
um I can say coordinates
and it has a default choice of
coordinates but these are formal symbols
because I don't want to clash with
pre-existing games so all I'm doing here
is I'm just saying uh well instead of
using that use a different coordinate
system use that for instance I see
so it's still it's just four coordinate
you know four-dimensional space time
there are four coordinates right it's
very it's very
old style to have just four coordinates
for space-time well okay yeah I mean uh
I can't have it in this version of the
code
it's not I can show you a version of the
code in an experimental version of the
code in a different branch in a minute
which has the generalizations of these
things to arbitrary uh complex
Dimensions although they get very very
complicated
um
dimensionality yes or no no no no no
really you can Define these things for
arbitrary yes so you you end up with a
uh essentially a hankel like uh well
okay with modified vessel functions and
modified Henkel functions for your
radial and and that come from uh that
come from these um spherical harmonics
uh for your radial and angular
coordinates um and then so the parts of
the complexity comes from the fact that
you can no longer represent these things
as a you know it as a normal tensor type
thing you can have a more abstract
notion of a tensor that can only be
expressed through projections
um and in fact in for the general
discrete space-time case that's the best
you can ever hope for really okay but so
so when you say okay so I understand
that the generalization of you know to
hyperspherical uh functions and I'm sure
that the minkowski version of that is
something maybe it's presumably vessel
rather than getting bar polynomials or
something right um the um or hankel
which is sort of like complex vessel or
something
um the uh
okay but what's less obvious to me and
maybe you've solved this is um
uh you know normally you've got vectors
of coordinates and you're and this
metric cancer is telling you distances
between vectors of coordinates but if
you're not in integer dimensional space
how are you even representing positions
well you have to give it vertices right
so
um I I can maybe demo this in okay all
right okay so this is this is really
going full you know hypergraph so that
requires me running an experimental
version of the code this is the more
established all right but the basic
point is that you say you define a
position not by a collection of
coordinates which would be you know what
we get by defining directions so to
speak but actually the way we think it
really should work of um of of defining
position by a node in the hypergraph I
mean so what you're saying about the uh
if I say metric
so for any given metric I can say length
pure function and it will synthesize a
symbolic piece of open language code
that computes uh uh distances you know
uh you know distances between arbitrary
four vectors if they're the case of
occur right that's that's effectively
what you're talking about of course in
the in the general discrete case we
can't do that but what we can do is so
these are effectively projections right
you are projecting
um you know a given tensor in some
direction or you know if we took
I said Richie tensor
metric
s
sorry no but I get the point what you're
doing is you're operationalizing the
notion of position
in I mean this is very lovely in um
you know because usually you think a
position is some collection of
coordinates with respect to these
directions in four-dimensional space
so this is this is how we take an
abstract tensor
oh how we Define an abstract tensor for
a kind of arbitrary combinatorial
structure right so it's just something
that you can give
an input vertex an output vertex a new
computer projection
and so you so it doesn't permit a nice
representative you know a nice linear
algebraic representation in terms of
matrices or arrays or whatever but you
but you can effectively stop you can you
can represent that tensor as just a
collection of all of its projections uh
which is really for instance
lovely
okay the I mean honestly this is just I
mean this is a a very interesting
merging of the um okay it just helps me
understand the relationship of the
quotes linear algebra by saying by
talking about linear algebra you are
essentially imagining that you are
making I don't know what there's a
mathematical term for it I mean that
this you know you're defining directions
which you don't get to do in a hypograph
only as an approximation what is that
what is that process called of defining
directions and that some I mean it's
some kind of um well it's effectively
defining a local coordinate basis right
I mean the notion of coordinates as such
is a notion that is beyond the hypograph
story well so the point is that it's it
requires having a notion I mean that's
what the notion of connection does right
um and so so the point is that
connections work in a connections are
much more general for hypocross than
they offer remote
that's the kind of the big picture story
okay explain explain that statement I
mean so a connection usually is giving
you the mapping of the coordinates from
one place to another but you're saying
here how should I think about the
generalization of that so a connection
here tells you effectively it is
essentially a rule for how you lift
um okay so for how for how you lift
um perturbations in where you apply a
hypograph yeah to hypergraph distances
in you know in in in in the in the hyper
surface
well right I mean that you know the
little piece of coordinate system
yeah I mean you could look at a local
region of hypergraph around some node
and you try to match that up with a
local region of hypergraph around some
other node and you're asking what
transmission should you make I don't
even know I don't even know how to
parameterize that transformation
well uh this is a topic for another
discussion but this actually relates to
some stuff that we've been working on
recently in relation to these algebraic
Quantum field models
um okay that which is uh
the okay so there's an evolution you
know okay this is a static metric so
it's not a very exciting Evolution but
there's the evolution of parameterized
in terms of hypographs so what's
happening here is in the general case
what we're doing is we're saying okay we
take the initial data
we produce a hypograph by a poisson
process
um that sort of that agrees with the
with the Continuum metrics up to some
discretization scale that's what the one
is doing yeah and then we just evolve
the thing in time as a koshy problem
using in this case the ADM equations
although the there's experimental
support for bssn and ccc4 and
um uh I hope you also support other
other kinds of initial value formula
okay so but the there is an underlying
hypergraph rewrite rule or you're
evolving
there's an underlying hypograph rewrite
rule which is what's doing the
refinement and coarsening there's there
are two right there's a there's a
refinement rule there's a coarsening
rule
um and then we're applying that rule in
places where it should be applied
according to the rules of AMR and so
effectively what we're doing is we're
defining a Wolfram model system whose
event selection function is determined
by a pde system
okay but but the pde so so are you
labeling the nodes in the hypergraph by
some continuous parameter or what yeah
so uh
if I
but then as I say the interesting thing
becomes then we can we can Recon because
we can reconstruct those continuous
parameters from the hypograph structure
and this is what there's you know some
research work going on at the moment
about exactly this about you know how
much information you lose if you
actually just kind of throw away the pde
system and you just retain the hypograph
topology and the answer is you lose a
lot but not as much as you might think
um and in the end
you know in the world I mean you know
we've got a lot of orders of magnitude
between the actual discrete microscopic
structure of space and what we actually
observe and to parametrize those many
orders of magnitude it is not an
unreasonable thing to think about just
labeling the nodes the hypograph by some
continuous parameter
um
right I mean yeah so in effect yeah you
you can think of the non
um the non-thrown away version as just
being a sort of coarse grained
approximation of a of a pure underlying
typography right right but the thing
that you're doing here in a sense is I
mean if one was doing finite differences
finite elements whatever the well
actually I don't even know the answer to
this this is a Rob who's been quite
silent or who's very popular sport
anybody here other than me knows this
the I mean in
in a standard finite element Evolution
process for a you know let's say a
random hyperbolic pde
are you
does one routinely change the mesh or is
the mesh something which is fixed
given the geometry of the problem
I mean in other words is this is this
thing because this is something which by
its own Dynamics is changing its analog
of the mesh
I mean is that something that in the
world of numerical analysis is that
something people routinely do or is that
something that that is kind of hard to
do consistently which is where these
models should come in is forcing I mean
I I can take a crack at the answer which
is so there's a I mean adaptive mesh
refinement does that in a very limited
way or in a very restricted sort of way
right so the so this the algorithm
that's being used here is a sort of
modified is a generalization of this
thing called The Burger oligar method
for for adaptive mesh refinement in
finite volume pde systems
um so so the idea there you know so in
the standards case you would have like a
Cartesian mesh
um and then you'd say okay well if you
have some indicator function in each
cell and then you say if the indicator
function exceeds some value then we
refine and we hierarchically refine that
cell
um and if it goes below a certain value
then we course on that cell and then you
have some ways for sort of projecting uh
fluxes and things from course cells to
fine cells and there's a bunch of
complexity about how you might defy the
stable time steps in the in the finer
regions and stuff but that's the sort of
that's the basic setup okay so it's kind
of like a tree-like hierarchical I mean
in the end you're going to get something
that has you know additional layers of
tree branching in different in certain
places in the in the uh in the mesh
right and in fact there's a there's a
method called adaptive refinement trees
that does you know represents it exactly
in that way
um and uh then in numerical relativity
people developed a bunch of methods for
doing AMR with more General kind of
curvilinear coordinate grids
this method is a little bit different at
least from those and I don't I mean
again this is maybe something where Rob
will know
um because I I don't know that much
about the finite element world I know
more about the finite volume world uh
but at least in the final so that this
is doing something that's a bit
different because it's not it's keeping
the topology of the hypograph
essentially completely unstructured
right so normally you would say uh I
hierarchically refine the cell but I
keep you know the the it's like a
self-similar
um coordinate you know coordinate grid
right like I I I'm still preserving the
kind of Cartesian coordinate topology
it's just like at a smaller scale
or in other words the the the the
changes to the message topology that I'm
making by doing the Adaptive refinement
are very very restricted
whereas for this algorithm they've
completely as unrestricted as they can
be uh because our coursing and refining
refining and closing procedure is given
by
um hyper Edge subdivision and Hyper Edge
smoothing so you literally just take an
edge between two vertices and then you
to refine you just plonk another vertex
in between and to coarsen you just take
a path of three vertices and you extract
the vertex in the middle
um and I don't know I I I suspect that
is sort of theoretically the most
unstructured form of
um you know right rough refinement that
you can do
all right anyway so okay so I think we
we understand roughly the framing of
what's going on so now
um
all right so you've got well keep going
you you had a you had an arc of
presentation here uh well I mean I I
don't know I'm trying to get a kind of a
high level overview of what's going on
um I don't know what what I mean okay so
okay so what are you first of all
defining is how do you set up the
initial conditions and your I mean you
know in terms of software design
it's like imagine
I mean if I were to want to put
a you know
black holes on the on the corners of a
pentagon or something or the corners of
a dodecahedron right what would um I
mean can you do that not as the not with
the framework because it's currently
developed but I do I mean as a kind of
General design thing I do want it to be
as modular as possible
um so for instance I mean like okay
right now so we've been dealing with
only with sort of vacuum space times so
far so if you know if I uh
so if I say this whole vacuum Einstein
equations you know we've been taking
things like the responsible metric
okay right it's assumed the non-zero
cosmological constant so it's saying
that it's not a true solution but okay
there we go so so that's a
it can confirm that that is in fact a
solution and it's an exact solution it's
not some you know it hasn't had to make
some numerical approximation or whatever
so how can you visualize that I mean so
that solution
I'm I'm confused isn't the metric the
solution so to speak what does it mean
to solve the antonym equations beyond
the metric is some arbitrary I mean so
the point is you can put some completely
random Matrix into metrics that's not
right yeah okay so only some of those
will be true metrics that are you know
that solve the action equations yes um
and and so so that's what's all sort of
vacuumation equations is checking it's
checking so it's Computing Richie tensor
Richie scalar Einstein tensor and then
checking that that's equal to zero okay
but wait a minute if it's saying solve
normally solve would be given a set of
conditions right generate me a solution
this doesn't really be doing that so if
I say uh
okay
um fllw or something right that's not a
vacuum solution
so if I say
um
solution two equals solve vacuum
Einstein equations okay but I'm going to
keep the cosmological constant in just
for fun
so it's saying not an exact solution and
it's saying four field equations
so here are the here are the equations
that would have to it's the minimal
system of equations that would have to
hold in order for this to be a true
solution to the vacuum Einstein okay
okay so so this is the analog not of
solve but of reduce I think maybe it
should be reduced yeah right because
because what this is doing is it's
giving you or is it even maybe something
slightly even slightly different from
that it's giving you the subsidiary
equations that would need to be
satisfied in order to have you know you
have something with more parameters
and it is telling you
these are you know these are subsidiary
conditions that have to be satisfied for
these things for this to work but now if
I if I were to give it
a metric tensor that is explicit metric
tensor you know just some random Matrix
yeah it's just going to say what's going
to do it's going to say forget it what's
it going to do what does solvent
equations back well okay if it's truly a
numerical Matrix I mean this okay this
is where we get into the problem with
physicists calling things tenses that
aren't really tenses right so
normally when we say metric tensor we
don't actually mean metric sensor we
mean metric sense of field right the the
the the it's the Schwartz child metric
is a metric tensor field over a geometry
um so it has coordinate dependence if
you truly meant just a metric tensor as
in like a numerical Matrix then there's
there isn't even a sensible way of
um defining Einstein equations for that
right it's just well I mean the
derivatives are all zero it doesn't
depend on exactly so I mean if we did if
I uh
best way to do this random real uh
does that work yeah
or something
um
oops uh oh right yeah okay it's it's
gonna complain because it's not it's not
symmetric make it symmetric yeah how do
we make hey somebody here Rob knows how
to make a symmetric Matrix well you can
do it just by adding stimer Thrice
it's going to give you a symmetris array
if you don't want that um
okay so if I do that and then Soul
vacuum Einstein equations okay well it's
obviously it's going to say
uh of with zero cosmological constants
it's going to say Goal Zero so if you
just say so look inside that object what
is it what's inside that object that
backing uh I mean so yeah I mean inside
that is not very much right if I just
say but if I say field equations it's
going to say there's nothing but what I
could do is I could say Richie sensor of
that
that's just going to be zero and that
would be identically zero
reaching okay Q will return true okay
great okay so now let's just try because
I'm I'm let's just try making a uniform
gravitational field
which is
well even a metric what the heck is that
in terms of metric I'm just thinking if
the metric was just equal to R for
example
given every projection
yeah I'm thinking well I don't know what
what is what is a uniform what is the
metric for it's probably something much
more complicated but I'm just trying to
think of the most naive
um it's not really the metric it's the
gravitational field which is more
complicated to compute but yeah just
just do something where the thing yes
it's constant like that now say cell
vacuum outstand equations what's it
going to do
splatter rule okay singular Matrix
well wait a second is that
um
okay okay
uh
so just quickly before we do that I did
want to show just as a um so if I if I
give it a stress energy distribution
right so if I say
he tends to do perfect fluid or
something
like
this but let's say stress energy not for
minkowski which is the default but for
schwarzen no let's do it let's do FLW
sorry
so then what I can do is I can say solve
Einstein equations
that
uh and
there we go okay
and so that will derive the general form
of the Friedman equations for arbitrary
cosmological constant and then obviously
um
yeah okay so if I were to say I have no
idea what it does but I mean a perfect
fluid like in the Cur
metric what the heck would that look
like it would be ugly uh there we go
that's what the stress energy tensor
looks like for a perfect fluid for a
perfect fluid in the in the curd
geometry
which is a perfect fluid meaning it's
isotropic pressure and all that kind of
stuff right right exactly so so the
perfect food is the one that's just
equal where it's just row plus P you
mean you you knew plus P times G menu
okay
so now what happens if you try and solve
your understanding equations in that
let's have a look uh it may not be able
to do it or may not be able to do it in
a reasonable time we'll see
but what would it mean I mean so it is
so so what so what it's doing I can I
can break down its competition right if
I
um so it's taking the code geometry it's
saying Richie tensor metric tents occur
okay so obviously that so we know that
occur is a vacuum solution so uh this
will return a non-zero thing
um you'll return some very complicated
measurements but if I say reduced Matrix
representation which will kind of
simplify by all um known algebraic
equivalences it will reduce to a zero
Matrix so so all it's doing is it's
saying Army it's setting up the Army Nu
minus and of course we could say in a
Richie scalar and all that kind of stuff
I mean but these things at certainly at
the origin it is not the case that it's
that the retreat answer is zero correct
I mean well it's not it's not defined
the metric isn't defined at the origin
um so it's the I mean this is why in a
sense we uh why one tends to say that
that um black holes are like
gravitational solitons right because
they are just like
you know the the vacuum Solutions except
for like a kind of Delta point you know
Delta function yeah
and I mean I don't know the the taxonomy
the zoo of solutions
but
other Solutions okay naive question are
there Solutions no one I mean there are
solutions where there is a point carved
out of the manifold
are there Solutions no mothers like a
line carved out of the manifold well in
cut in color it's a path right it's a
ring
right
um and there was a recent I mean okay
basically my understanding is there's
comparatively little known about what
the topology of possible
um you know what what topologies are
possible space-time singularities can
exist
um like a question I've always been
curious about is could you how can you
have ones with kind of ambient with
arbitrary ambient isotopy groups can you
have a singularity that's you know
that's uh that's isotopic to uh you know
to a trefoil loss or something and I
have never been able to find the answer
to that question
um
I don't know if Jose knows anything
about
Singularity structure nope nope I cannot
no no that's interesting though okay I
mean
that that you know
that whole thing
in the case of
of hypergraphy writing
that
what does that mean I mean so when
there's a point Singularity it means
there is a place in the hypergraph where
you know no more rules apply
so uh yeah right so okay
this is actually the topic of the paper
here I'm working on this is the thing in
the background right this is me
investigating the the idea behind this
is to look at other Singularity theorems
true in discrete space times and what do
you need to modify about them you know
like are there any differences right so
here's like an example of a
gravitational collapse uh to a to a of a
an initially historically symmetric Mass
distribution
um this is something that limits to
responsible geometry here's the
corresponding uh down here here's the
corresponding gravitational collapse to
occur geometry an extreme or geometry
that's the initial scale of field
configuration and this is what it
collapses down to
um and so
should I consider it significant there's
a big gap in that typograph uh well that
that's effectively the interior and
exterior Event Horizon separating off
from each other
really yeah
um and so actually in the limit it
splits off as so as the point is as J
over M goes to one because the typograph
becomes disconnected in that limit well
I know that but I mean so if you did
that for a schwarzshilt in the schwart
shield case
there is no similar disconnection is
that no no this this disconnection
occurs entirely because of the
non-trivial Event Horizon structure of
the card geometry as it approaches
externality
and what happens in I mean if you is
there any way of getting other I don't
remember this like ryzen and Nordstrom
have different is that just like Cur or
does it have extra stuff in it it's
pretty much like I mean like we support
it I mean but you wouldn't want rice and
Nordstrom you'd want current human right
which is
non-rotating charged nucleus rotating
charged okay so this is what chronium
looks like but effectively it's like the
same geometry
um but the the charge here Q just has
the effect of changing the effective
Mass
but
okay okay okay
all right I mean sorry what I was going
to comment about that though is the uh
so
um the way that the thing you know the
way that Singularity is defined in the
context of the singularity theorems is
in terms of geodesic incompleteness
right so you you essentially say you you
take a GDC congruence uh and then you
ask you know can I extend these you know
can I extend these gd6 arbitrarily far
as analytic functions of the affine
parameter or the time parameter and if
the answer is no then we can say well
that's probably because they've hit some
space-time obstruction and then the you
know the essence of the singularity
theorems is showing that from the the
ray chowder equation that describes how
the geometries of this GDC congruences
evolve that as long as you have a
trapped surface and you have reasonable
energy conditions that you always get
geodesic and completeness so that the
nice thing is that that admits a very
natural formulation in terms of
hypographs and causal graphs because uh
I mean you can see it right over here
somewhere
I'm gonna I'm about to ask about the no
hair theorem and how that how you see
that in a hypograph that is so this is
this is a this is an example of a this
is a signal a singularity signature in
the in the console graph right so there
comes a point where this causal geodesic
just cannot be extended right so the the
causal graph just ends at that point
that path has finite length and however
much you apply the hypergraph rules that
path is never going to extend that's the
animals of GDC and completeness and so
the the analog of the question we were
just asking would be can you have uh a a
a congruence of geodesics in the causal
graph that cannot be extended by
applying hypography writing
um which where that where the end points
of that congruence form a non you know
topologically non-trivial structure in
the hyper yes yes
and and the answer is uh I don't know
okay let me know in a few weeks but
isn't known yet we don't know in the in
the Continuum space-time case like no I
understand that okay that's been 100
years but that that we're expecting fast
to turn around here well at least I mean
we we can we can test it reasonably
systematically I guess right but okay so
just is there an intuition about the no
hair theorems of why you know from an
arbitrary configuration of um
uh of initial hypograph that there is
some sense in which
you is that obvious from from what you I
mean is that
it's it's obvious as long as you don't
have
um you know long-range hypercraft
connections I mean all of that saying is
that once you know once you've collapsed
Beyond this region here if you are if
you're on the outside of this hypograph
then the only features of what's going
on inside this region that you can
extract are very very course I mean
that's really what the notepad therms
are saying well right but it's saying
that the connection between
the inside and the outside is
is through hypergraph
you know you're saying if there were
things that reached kind of Wormhole
like things that reached right into the
center
then you could be detecting features of
the center from far away I mean
you know what what
insofar as most of the distance on the
hypergraph you know it's this thing with
threads that that um I wanted about ages
ago
um right and actually I I think I
mentioned this in an email but my new
conjecture is that your quantum
mechanics idea from nks is much more
plausible as a dark matter candidate
than as a quantum mechanics candidate
in mind yes yes well let's think about
that for a second so I mean I I'm
so
you're saying the point with the no
headphones is okay so as a general
feature of these typograph models one of
the things it means okay what's it mean
to say that it has a Continuum limit
well one of the conditions that it has
to satisfy in order to have a Continuum
limit is that it doesn't have
arbitrarily long-range connections
between different points in space right
yes or at least not many of them well
yeah yeah yeah they have to form a
whatever vanishingly small subsets or
something
um and so
that effectively means that the amount
of information that you can glean about
a distant region of the hypograph is
necessarily limited if you're in some
other region of the hypograph yep and
the no hair theorems are just the
special case of that where it says well
if you're you know on the other side of
the Event Horizon then you have limited
information there's limited information
you can glean about what's on the other
side and you know that and you know this
is the no hair thermist like the
theorems are sort of the degenerate case
where it says well the actually the only
thing is you can do these are uh you
know Mass angular momentum um and charge
um
so the long-range connection thing would
be saying well you know maybe there are
cases where that isn't true you know
some some degrees of freedom somehow
leak out and so you can have kind of
black holes that exert gravitational
influence over a much larger region of
space than they should you know
according to the Continuum Theory
um and if that happens for say
supermassive black holes
you know that could potentially extend
language and stuff
um that's amusing I mean so but what
would it actually look like I mean is it
is it a correction to the I mean the one
over R potential so to speak one of our
yeah the the um you know the normal
what what it's going to do is it's going
to change the GD stick it's going to
change the area of the geodesic ball so
to speak by having go ahead it would
effectively say that the the weak field
limit in gr is not valid in the places
where you think it's valid right you
know so so you you it's standards to and
it's it's a common way that you derive
things in GIS you say you want
consistency with the you want the
Einstein potential to be consistent with
the Newtonian potential in some weak
field limit so you want the one over r
squared you know Phi thing
um and but is there a long-range
hypograph connections then that's not
going to be you know then then it's not
going to be the case that you know even
arbitrarily far away from a from a um
uh black hole or something it's not
going to be the case that the weak field
limit necessarily apply you know you
don't get or you know asymptotic
flatness doesn't mean what you've
thought it meant so to speak
um well put another way I mean
you're trying to fit you've got this
hypograph and you're trying to model
like a manifold as you know euclidean
space is the microscopic model of what's
happening in a manifold and in a sense
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to fit
I'm trying to understand this you're
trying to fit some Continuum picture on
top of something which has a bunch of
threads in it a bunch of long-range
threads
and the question is what does the the
fitted Continuum picture what does that
look like when there are these
long-range threads
I mean in other words if you
and well I mean I mean presumably it's
the I mean the the the standard way to
do it would be to have some you know
would have would be to change the
homotopy group right it's just to say
you know model those long range threads
as like little you know Wormhole like
things that that yeah these holes
if there are a large number of
microscopic wormholes that reach from
the center of our galaxy to the outer
reaches of our galaxy what does that do
I don't I don't know
uh let's think about it for a second I
mean in
in
and those wormholes it's not like you
know you'd normally think about those as
being in space but they're not in space
it's not like you it's not like oh
you're traveling around a spacecraft and
suddenly you reach one of these you know
you reach the edge of the side of a
wormhole there is no side of the
Wormhole the Wormhole is is reaching
from place a to place B not going
through what you attribute you know as
you as your spacecraft goes along it can
never go into that Wormhole so to speak
it doesn't make any sense in other words
the the Wormhole this this thread is
going let's say from the center of the
you know Central black hole of the
Galaxy out to some random out of you
know it's it's terminating somewhere
when I say it's terminating somewhere
what I mean is that there is a
background sort of manifold-like model
by euclidean space at a small scale or
minkowsky space or whatever the small
scale thing
um but you know and when you're tooling
around in a spacecraft that's all you'll
ever see
and the question is
what would happen is
if you look at the um
Okay so
to say there are additional threads
is to say that
let's think about this is this obvious
this this there's some obvious way to
think about this in terms of just you
know normally the the the volume of that
GDC ball is R to the D
but somehow
the number of um uh let's think
well I can't quite figure this out in
real time
but maybe since you bring that up I I
don't have an answer what's your
question but since you bring it up and
say I know it's one of your favorite
features of your money in Geometry I
should just say that we can do things
like uh is it I I think it's important
it's about the only one I know you know
I can't remember the property names now
um
scalar volume expansion
so it will this this is the expansion of
the volume of a GDC ball relative to the
volume of the corresponding of all of
the corresponding radius Epsilon in
minkowsky Space the unsimplified form if
I do they're simplified this is a vacuum
solution to simplify something trivial
but it can also do the directed case
right so you can say things like quality
form expansion
will give you so this is now the uh
volume of a geodesic cone projected in a
given Direction relative to the volume
of the corresponding cone in
things like that well okay so there's a
lot of very interesting stuff here so
let's talk about
um okay we we had wanted to make sure we
covered sort of software design aspects
of this I mean right I mean so I have I
have three primary concerns right which
was the reason I I wanted to call this
meeting one is I want to make sure that
whatever you and The Institute and
things have planned for numerical gr
that it's you know that we're not
duplicating effort and this is sort of
the kind of thing that you want I think
you've gotten a lot further than
everybody else has got
um that may be true but also I mean it
is is this I don't actually know what
the plans are there so I I'm the the I'm
I'm um uh it's not an event horizon it's
just a lack of it's just my um uh
um let's put it this way my yes it is an
effective one because I've been
accelerating in other directions which
have caused me to not be able to get
signals quickly enough from uh uh um
from that so yes so I don't know
um good question and I I don't um
okay
um and then but this is the the other
two things that slightly worried me are
okay so obviously in doing this I've had
to implement a bunch of symbolic tensor
functionality both sort of tensor
algebra stuff for doing you know raising
lowering indices doing contractions and
so on but also a bunch of tensor
calculus stuff so if you know if I take
this you know I can say
a very derivatives or something and it
will compute an association of all
covariant derivatives of the Richie
tensor and and so you know and and so
um
it's not it's nowhere near as general as
something like exact where you can sort
of build up arbitrary tensor equations
and things but it's the the goal at
least my goal was to have all the sort
of tensor algebra tensor calculus
functionality that you would want to
have in a basic kind of general
relativity package or right which I
don't think we've you know
I mean Jose should comment on this but I
feel like we
the convenient things to do for General
activity
uh the things that we might do for sort
of completely General tensors are not
particularly convenient you know if if
that's what we're doing it won't be
particularly convenient for General I
don't know Jose do you want to comment
on this
so I think there are some things here
which
um would be quite useful as individual
functions like Computing the Richie
tensor from a metric it's a standard
computation that people would appreciate
and and so and and I've seen that that
exists already as a wfr function so
so that type of thing in it takes some
time to set up an exact because in
excite you have to set up the first
manifold on a coordinate system so it's
multiple lines of code well yeah I see
you can do it quite quickly which is
nice
uh but then yes this type of approach
has can do what can do but but you
cannot build up General things
because what
because why because uh you may want to
have arbitrary objects that your problem
has like suddenly you want to have a new
Vector
obeying some properties of with respect
to some other derivatives that you have
introduced right so so the way this is
working exactly is by setting up a bunch
of objects that at the end you are going
to use all together and people will
spend some time building up this the
environment because they know they are
going to be working quite a lot with
that environment for whole paper many
equations that sort of thing right right
so so this is kind of the Dual approach
which which the uses of exact has have
complained about sometimes so it takes
some time it takes much time to to get
to something so another question is the
bridge between this and exact right and
whether there's a you know whether you
could essentially com generate exact
stuff from
this easier to get started with
technology
I I think that's I think that's probably
a very sensible thing to do because yeah
like the
um the I mean oh as Jose said uh you
know the key limitation with this is
obviously if you want to build up some
some new tensor right that some
combination of you know contractions of
real intenses and bile tenses or
whatever like there's no way to do that
and to do that in generality you would
need a framework that is at least as
powerful as exact and you know I have no
plans to you know that's already been
done I have no plans to re-implement
that
um so
exact fill it feels like exact feels it
feels a different Niche
um if you just want to do kind of Fairly
standards general relativity
calculations I'm trying to make that as
easy as possible to do with this uh but
as soon as you want anything more
advanced you probably will have to go to
exact or something equivalent okay but
let's talk about the workflow here
because I mean you know one of the
things I mean I have a
a parochial interest here in just being
able to do
enough general relativity
with something that has you know an
underlying you know hypergraph structure
that
and we can study the you know the
phenomenology of those things did this
is this workflow straightforward I mean
is this kind of what you had in mind so
this is an important I think so but I
just haven't thought through what I mean
I mean let's take the example of the
Galaxy with its Central black hole okay
okay let's imagine that we want to
actually solve we want to know does this
make dark matter
right okay let's talk about what would
be involved in doing that
so we'd have a central black hole we'd
ask the question what what we might be
asking is
um given some distribution of of mass or
something of things falling into black
hole is it the case that the hypergraph
we get has little tentacles coming out
of the black hole and what effect would
they have that we presumably want to
watch a judiciq move around the thing
and ask questions about you know what it
does let's show how you would do that
right so if I say
this
so there are various I mean just
evolving the the metric is one class of
numerical computation you can do but
there are various kinds of numerical
content
functions so hang on let me think about
this for a second but I want initial
coordinates something like that so it's
outside the Event Horizon let's do I
think the uh orbital velocity for a mass
what for a unit Mass black hole is is 1
8. so let's say l is our I find
parameter to uh organization
this may or may not work
let's have a look
um so the I mean and the way that this
works is due to a very nice
correspondence that we've known about
for some time between essentially
solving geodesic equations in uh
ramanian geometry and uh producing
um you know and finding shortest paths
in in graphs right with with some
weighting so this is a responsible
geometry with a with a geode system this
is this should be a circular orbit
Okay so
the background graph here
is what before you put the GD stick on
it it's it's this it's it's the
structural metric okay okay just redrew
itself in a weird way okay uh yeah I
mean we I can coordinateize it if you
want no no no no I'm happy with that so
so then what you're saying is
if I look at those JD six
then
the question is I mean because what you
want is an evolving black hole which
isn't I mean what if you just take this
partial metric and you sprinkle the
schwatch up metric you've already cooked
the answer so to speak right right which
so this is why so in general you would
want to so this metric tensor would be
something that's produced by ADM
decomposition
you set up the initial hypersurface
geometry you ADM decompose it you impose
whatever gauge conditions you want you
get out a symbolic metric tensor you
then discretize it using this function
and you give it some parameters and you
evolve a thing in time
okay but so a naive thing to do would be
start off with sort of the Galaxy as it
was when it was young so to speak
um
I have no idea other this is a I sort of
have a I sort of booked a time to talk
to a old astrophysics cosmology friend
of mine about about this but we haven't
gotten around to it yet you should join
that
um about uh okay other uh are there age
effects in Dark Matter observed in
galaxies do you know
in other words if if you look at a young
Galaxy like I know there are galaxies
now people have found I mean recently a
few weeks ago has announced like
galaxies from 130 million years after
the big bang
um does one know if there are different
rotation curves for Galaxies that are
really old compared to newer galaxies
I have no idea um Jose do you happen to
know no I don't know either
um my my guess would be no
um yeah that's what I have never heard
of that I mean it's one of the things
where if there were a discrepancy I
would have thought I'd know about it but
right unless unless it wasn't unless
it's hard to measure the rotation curves
hmm
but but okay but but so then I mean the
question would be if you have a thing
that is going to you know like okay
here's another naive question which I
should know don't know the answer to if
you look at a Galaxy as a function of
age like our galaxy I don't know what
it's it's you know whatever it is it's
how old is our galaxy anyway I don't
even know that it's terrible I don't
know that I think it has a 200 million
year rotation time
I don't know how old it is
um I only know that from the Monty
Python song
um well our own Galaxy you mean
yeah how old is our galaxy
I mean it it has gone many
Browns so no no I know that but
you think it's 10 billion years old
something like that I don't know I have
no idea I mean we're not a first
generation star but but um
um in um
uh
yeah
I don't know
I see a thing saying the web says 13.6
billion but I don't think that's
necessarily at all correct
I mean that would be that would make it
very young
no 13 that would mean it was a one
billion years well yeah I mean yeah
sorry as it was it was produced when the
universe was very inhale that's right
yeah I don't think it's realistic at all
I think that's only a very high red
shift that you get to something like
that
um anyway but but my question would be
okay so the question I was going to ask
is
you know can you compute
okay Google does and and
um okay hang on wait let me check the
source of this
there are a bunch of people saying that
that uh some parts of it were formed
about 800 million years after the
recombination
which would so 13.6 billion is not too
far all right okay okay well then then
the question is how has the size of the
central black hole changed over time
you know presumably there are
unlucky Stars that fall into the central
black hole but I have no idea what
causes I mean there's some viscosity
presumably that's causing them to
uh lose anger momentum
yeah anyway but the the question would
be
okay there's clearly a bunch of
astrophysics that I need to learn here
um but I'm I'm just trying to understand
in terms of the workflow of this system
so I mean I I think what you I mean so
here you can see this is the time so
here we're evolving both the metric and
the uh um and this GD sick
actually not its functions of time but
its functions of the affine parameters
although you could evolve in those
functions of time so you can do kind of
co-evolution you could do this with if
you took a stress energy you know uh uh
I won't do it here because it would take
too long but if you know if I take a
stress energy distribution like this uh
then obviously it has
certain continuity equations that it has
to satisfy which effectively just says
the covariant Divergence goes to zero
um and then so if you close the system
with constitutive relation to you with
an equation of State then you can
co-evolve a metric and a stress energy
distribution in time together so you
could use that to simulate things like
you know fluid accretion onto black
holes or whatever it was so the basic
workflow would be you know set up the
metric or possibly the initial data for
the metric set up the Mata Fields
distribution like perfect food or
whatever it is
um uh then you know then co-evolve the
metric and the matter distribution or
the metric and the geodesic or whatever
um you know forwards in time and see
what happens
okay so the we're about to run out of
time unfortunately we'll have to
continue another time but but um uh you
know
big cause of questions right so this is
supposed to reproduce the Einstein
equations
and there are sort of numerical analysis
I mean because basically that the big
picture would be number one you know
does it reproduce the Einstein equations
when it should and number two if you
kind of overclock it and start having it
show its typographism what happens
right I mean so there's an interesting
quasi-philosophical point which is that
in in conventional numerical gr you know
there are a bunch of situations where
you'll get some crazy answer and you'll
say oh well this is clearly just like a
grid effect
yeah the point is that actually with a
lot of the stuff that happens in the
physics project it's exactly the grid
effects that we want to see exactly yes
yes we want to overclock the uh the
thing and watch the thing fall apart
right like like for instance okay so
with Cartesian or even with curvilinear
grids uh with finite volume schemes if
you have like a shock wave say a
strongly relativistic shock wave
um then you get a bunch of dispersions
that occur uh normal to the um to the to
the cell boundaries
um so you get sort of a lot of kind of
numerical dispersive noise that happens
when you as the shock front passes
through and a lot of effort is put into
uh so try trying to trying to tame those
dispersions and and introduce uh sort of
um synthetic diffusion terms and things
to get rid of them
um but obviously an interesting question
is what happens if you don't get rid of
them and you do the thing in a more
General hypograph topology would you
start to see
um you know deviation if you've got a
relativistic shock front moving through
a hypergraph you know does the do the
gravitational wave signatures look
different
um or notice yeah I bet you'll have shot
noise of some kind in the grotation
waves
right
that would be very cool and now the
question is well well what so okay so
this thing relativistic shock front
going through producing what you know I
would qualitatively think of as sound
waves
um
and okay so here's the question I
suppose for for the
okay we already have a model of this
which is molecules right so when a shock
front comes through a Hypersonic shock
comes through and
there are effects that are associated
with I mean they're almost chemical
effects associated with molecules
you know when you get whatever it is the
Hudson number or whatever that isn't
quite the council number it's a
different
when it's a strong enough shock that
okay the the
I mean the question that one should ask
perhaps is how does the presence of
molecules how does the fact that the
shock goes down to the level of
molecules affect the sound that is
generated from a Hypersonic shock
right that would be the physical that
will be the everyday quotes everyday
analog so in other words if you if you
are hearing the space shuttle or
whatever or some uh
some Modern analog of that
uh you know which
re-enters the atmosphere at what Mark 25
or something it has very
it shocks are
very
you know they're small compared to the
main three path I'm sure there are
molecular effects
what does that mean for the
um what does that mean for the distant
you know the non-neirfield sound waves
that are being generated from that hmm
one should just diagram I could look
that up I don't know what the answer is
but I mean so that's what Welsh
football's asking is what are the
non-neirfield gravitational wave effects
from a relativistic shock going through
space-time
um
and
what would make it
what kind of a thing would happen there
well I mean you know the most obvious
signature will be something in the
frequency spectrum
and in particular something where I mean
the the cool thing to happen
one would be that there's something that
you see in in them uh just like in the
um
you know when you get to the edge of the
Boron Zone and condensed matter physics
or something where you see the the
lattice effect that you see some bizarre
redshifted version of that that causes
some some um cliff in the in the
frequency spectrum of the of the
gravitational radiation that's coming
out right that's a good that's a good
phenomenological physics exercise which
I I'm way too rusty at to be able to do
in real time
um but uh uh but that's a super
interesting I mean yeah I mean being
able to validate this so I mean that's
the question validating this against the
Einstein equations so that one knows
that it's going to give I mean if it
gives as decent results as your average
Einstein equation code for the cases
where I mean you know what do we know we
know that black hole mergers work
roughly as Einstein equations so they
should work and
uh right and and I mean this so this has
been we've done well I've done some
um you know convergence analysis against
some standard numerical relativity test
cases so uh there are things like there
these have weird names like you know the
Gowdy wave test the apples for apples
test and uh and and yeah right other way
to um you know head-on collisions
between black holes and and things and
yeah we get you know quadratic
convergence to
or at least quadratic convergence to the
standard Solutions
um so this is not trivial I mean aren't
the standard Solutions isn't this
usually a super computer adventure to do
any of these numerical GRS Solutions or
is that was it yeah yeah uh or at least
I mean for for reasonable mesh sizes
yeah
but so is this competitive with that I
mean can you if if you make
you know a big enough hypograph
how big do I mean to make something that
is competitive in terms of precision
with typical kind of supercomputer you
know finite volume whatever it is
approximations
what what does it take how big a hyper
golf do you have to have so you can get
away with sort of ostensibly lower
resolutions precisely because there's
more information encoded in the
hypograph topology
um so for you know as a very basic test
case I was looking at these relativistic
shock these Riemann problems
relativistic shock waves and it seemed
like you could get so to get a something
that was comparable with having a
thousand cells of a standard Cartesian
grid uh you could get away with having
on you know on the region of 200 to 300
vertices in a corresponding hydrographer
yeah
well we should do it for elasticity
Theory as well because
that's a you know if it would work if it
did the same kind of thing for
elasticity theory that would be a hugely
useful thing I think in in the pde world
but but to give me a sense I mean in in
modern you know when people do official
black hole merger calculations how big
is their mesh and so on uh okay that's
like because of precisely because of AMR
that's a complicated question to answer
so I mean uh for instance this um one of
the test cases I was comparing against
they started with a base grid resolution
of I think 800 by 800
um but but up to four levels of
refinement depth
so 800 to the fourth power or what oh
yeah sorry yes yeah they were showing
two-dimensional projections of the
services so it was 800 by 800 but yeah
um 800 to the part four for the overall
okay sorry 800 to the power three
because you're evolving the
three-dimensional
so that's not a huge amount of memory I
mean we're not talking about I mean is
this in the usual case is this a GPU
Adventure where or is it that the mesh
refinement causes you to not be able to
parallelize things in that way uh it
certainly can be parallelized but that's
a that's an open area of research is how
you parallelize AMR algorithms just in
general numerical analysis
um right but I mean so the thing I'm
trying to understand is if you know to
do it will be good it seems to me to be
able to do a really high accuracy
you know black hole merger calculation
with this technology and I'm just
wondering as a practical matter how does
one do that I mean is it like get a big
computer and just run what you already
have or are there more steps that have
to be done
uh I think that I think that's pretty
much it I mean the the only thing that's
complicated okay so the so the point is
that the bottleneck or at least the
thing which you can readily parallelize
is the computation of the of the fluxes
right so across each Edge you
effectively have to compute an intervert
X flux
and those can be fully paralyzed right
they they they don't have any
independencies on each other
um and so that would you know if if you
could if you could it probably wouldn't
require that much modification to the
code but if you could you know if you
could Shard that onto different parallel
instances then you could quite easily
run that on a cluster with probably
reasonable speed up
right although you have to be able to
communicate back the results of the
fluxes
you know it's not obvious that the
community I mean it's a complicated
question whether the community well I
mean actually the reason for doing the
intercell flux or the into vertex fluxes
is precisely to make it not a
complicated question because the point
is that that's um is it embarrassingly
parallel is that the phrase yeah yeah um
it's one of the it's one of these things
where you you literally just all you
have to do is send to each uh to each
thread
um a collection for a fourth order
scheme you'd have to send whatever um
eight vertices uh the information in
eight vertices it goes away it does some
numerical pde solving sends back a
number one's all the threads have
computed their number you put you know
you send them back to the main instance
then you run your time Evolution step
and you do the thing again there's no
um complicated coordination or anything
required yeah except you have to you
have to sort of synchronize between each
step which is not you know like if
you're doing a solid automaton for
example you could be just the stuff
that's happening over here really can
happen independently the stuff that's
happening over there you don't have to
synchronize by time step the problem is
if you if you want to if you if
precisely the thing you want to
investigate are long-range Connections
in the hypograph you can't make that
assumption I know that but I I suspect
that most of what look we haven't really
worked that hard on parallelizing the
type of golf stuff and I bet it can be
paralyzed perhaps more so than the
Adaptive Mass refinement can be
parallelized
but I guess I guess as a
um
okay so I mean I'm just sort of curious
from a numerical I see a comment on our
live stream here
which has words in it that I don't know
but um uh asking simpler question
gravitational collapse to slide chill
which is interesting from the hypergraph
point of view that of uh
chopped Twix scalings this is this is
Jose's research area
okay yes can you understand the
universality of collapse from hypographs
can somebody unpack that question
I think Jose should probably
I wouldn't know I mean it would it would
be a matter of doing the experiments and
the typical game here is to fine tune
the initial conditions that you get
closer and closer to our next
singularity
so you are trying to produce the
smallest possible black hole and in the
regime in which we are you are
approaching the zero Mass black hole
juicy scaling and
this is the scaling this is the
phenomenon that I think you've told me
about before Jose about this yeah the
the the the construction of a naked
Singularity
so I I will say one thing and so I I am
not including the data in this paper
um because it's already sort of Beyond
this it's beyond the scope but I have
actually looked at the chocolate scale
of field uh bubble collapse problem
um to try because I mean
you know these are referred to as
relativistic critical phenomena right
um and the reason is because of a bunch
of analogies with with you know uh
critical phenomena physics the
interesting thing that I saw in the
hypograph cases that it's actually not
really an analogy right the that the
things you get in condensed matter
systems to do with ergodicity breaking
become literally breaking of the weaker
this is the hypothesis for the you know
for the hypergraph evolution
um so it's sort of it there's a
possibility there that you can give some
quite qualitative explanation of why the
you know why you get the ringing
behavior and things like the choptic
solution
um in terms of something that's not just
analogous but actually sort of
mathematically so what you mean is that
normally in the hypograph it's kind of
flapping around you know intrinsically
randomly so to speak
um uh and what you're saying is that in
these cases where you're trying to uh
sort of titrate down to a tiny black
hole but you end up with something where
just like in the case when you when you
get to a singularity the thing is
definitely not ergotic anymore the
evolution is definitely not ergotic when
it's stopped
um and so what you're saying is this is
a case there's another case there's a
different situation in which the
evolution becomes non-argotic right and
okay so just qualitatively in terms of
what that means I mean so one way you
can characterize weak organicity for the
hypograph system in general is you say
okay well as I said earlier you know the
way the place where we apply these
refinements or questioning the you know
the typography writing rules is
determined based on um you know gauge
conditions and things that we impose on
the metric
um so in general the question is can you
if you knew that a rule just got applied
over here can you predict where the next
rule is going to be applied and if it's
weakly ergotic the answer should be well
you know it's sort of computationally
irreducible
um but the interesting thing with the
Chopstick solution is that as the scale
of field bubble reaches the uh
approaches to Stone Schwartz child
radius the typography writing Dynamics
become progressively more deterministic
so you you it becomes like there's a
much more constrained area in which the
hypographic writing rules are being
applied uh to the point where I suspect
in the limit you can actually
deterministically predict with fairly
minimal computation where the rules are
going to be applied that would
correspond to a Breaking of organicity
well or more to the point it's freezing
I mean the thing froze and what you're
saying is one form of I mean space time
froze
uh well so some regions of space-time
will temporarily freeze yeah yes right
let's say
which is and Frozen in a different way
than the freezing as in there are no
more it's not the case that you get to a
singularity where there are simply no
more rules to apply
it's something that
uh you know it might not be that there
are no more rules to apply it's just
that the rules that are being applied
are being applied in a sort of regular
crystal lattice it's actually something
it's it works again this is purely
numerical data that I've looked at so
it's this is I I haven't sort of
formalized this at all but the way I
think the way I sort of thought about it
was that it's almost like the complement
of a singularity a singularity is is
something where the organicity is broken
because you can't apply a rule in some
place yep whereas for critical phenomena
what seems to happen is you get a
situation where the rule has to be
applied in a certain place yeah right
right which is what I was saying I mean
the analogy would be that
um it is a solid as a it's a crystalline
solid space-time you know the the
concept would be space time becomes a
crystalline solid where as opposed to a
gas or liquid where there's you know all
sorts of random updates going on
that's right I mean go ahead sorry the
standard interpretation of of critical
phenomena and gravitational collapse is
that it's a dynamical system so it has
basins of attractions it's one with an
attractor that's the know-her theorem
but the basis of attractions have
boundaries which themselves are uh
dynamical systems because we are do once
you are on the boundary you cannot leave
it and so the bundle itself has an
attractor with code Dimension One there
is one unstable mode the one that would
take you to the two attractors and so
you do fine tuning to kill that mode and
to stay as close as possible in the to
the to the boundary and so as as long as
you stay in the boundary do
um you get close to the attractor in the
boundary basically saying there's a
crater and there's the bottom of the
crater which you would normally go to by
virtue of some kind of you know gradient
descent type thing because you are
somehow keeping yourself circulating
around the rim of the crater
exactly and that Rim has its own
attractor and so if you manage to stay
close she's not close enough to the ring
for a long time then you will reach the
attacker and that attractor is the new
Singularity that Chopstick fall then
naked Singularity so it it doesn't have
to be a singularity just happens it
happens to be a singular solution it
could have been a solution which is not
singular but the important thing is that
this is a method to find new almost
stable Solutions right I don't think
that's in the system but what Jonathan
is saying in terms of I mean in this
this interpretation of the crystalline
crystallization of space-time
this is the player role here it's it's a
matter of finding a very very particular
point in in face space not a matter of
of going through the whole Space press
space if I understood right but the
failure of algorithity but by saying
you're circulating on the rim that's
saying you don't go visit other places
that would be the ergotic thing to do I
mean the ergotic thing to do is you
wander randomly
um
and uh
I really like this concept of of this
possibility that you know which you
could see in the causal graph presumably
of the formation of a crystal basically
yeah I mean I I mean Jose is right like
I I it's still a bit mysterious what
what exactly the connection is between
organicity breaking and the
self-similarity in face space that you
see for
um for you know for standards um you
know conventional
um
I could just see breaking oh a
relatively critical phenomena stuff uh
sorry I'm just I'm distracting I'm
trying to pull up some pictures if I can
of the Chopstick solution if I can find
the
um I have to go and I'm I'm
about to jump into an utterly different
but yeah I mean this is not a very good
picture but this is this is a place
where you you start this this sort of
regularity that you see in the causal
graph is the the foot I mean this is a
low resolution simulation but it's the
first indication you get of um this is
as you're approaching criticality as
you're approaching the the critical
radius for the choptick solution right
just imagine if that was bigger and you
could it was just going back and forth
back and forth just like a crystalline
solid
that's my my comment I mean if you
imagine
um maybe it's
wrong analogy but I I seems Seems
interesting to me this is great it's
really great I think yeah that to be
continued
um I I see Michael in a live stream
asking
when will this be released it's all
available right it's all on GitHub
um
and the so so uh as god mentioned I
think right at the beginning I'm in the
process of documenting and releasing
these functions also on wfr So Right Now
metric tensor Richie tensor are
documented uh a bunch of others are
about to be released on the wfl but if
you want to use all of this I'm just
running this directly from the GitHub
repository so if you want to run this
cool can do that let's um we should save
this file this was a good demo all right
yes
um the uh
all right I I should run along here but
but let's um uh I feel like we didn't
you know there was nothing obvious to me
where it was like oh that's an obvious
design mistake
um yeah uh but I would like to now that
I understand a little bit more what's
going on I'd like to dig in some more in
addition to design you know let's see if
we can figure out what dark matter is
that will be a little you know in
addition to the software design why not
um uh
um why not solve a physics problem while
we're at it
um
I think uh uh sounds to me like some
astrophysics input is needed there and
maybe we can arrange to get some of that
I mean just like uh this
phenomenological facts that I don't know
for example
um all right well this is uh quite
wonderful and um yeah exciting I know
now I'm I need to go read your paper
about um axiomatic Quantum field Theory
as well which I
um
keep on being deflected by by
uh by AIS of various kinds
um but uh uh all right
sounds good all right we should we
should wrap up here thanks a lot
Jonathan this is great
um and uh
so thanks to folks on the live stream
see you all soon
yes